[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen an diesem
pfingstsonntag im sport katja geht es ja
unter anderem um die neuen facebook wenn
sie der ein altbekannter ist rafael
nadal hat zum vierzehnten mal das
turnier in paris gewonnen das dann
gleich ausführlich jetzt schauen wir
erstmal auf die anderen themen dieses
tages
raketenangriffe auf 4 vor russland
beschießt wieder die hauptstadt der
ukraine und der osten des landes bleibt
schwer umkämpft
ein großbrand und viele opfer in
bangladesch starben mehr als 40 menschen
als in einem lagercontainer feuer fangen
und chemikalien explodieren
großbritannien feiert elisabeth die
zweite ein mega konzert zum
thronjubiläum lunch partys im ganzen
land und die queen die trinkt tee mit
patrick
zu pfingsten hat der papst eindringlich
zu verhandlungen über ein ende des
ukraine krieges aufgerufen führt die
menschheit nicht in den ruin so
franziskus der russische präsident putin
setzt dagegen weiter auf krieg und droht
mit schweren angriffen auf neue ziele
sollte der westen der ukraine rakete mit
hoher reichweite liefern heute beschoss
das russische militär auch das erste mal
seit wochen wieder die hauptstadt mit
raketen alexandra vacano
die menschen heute früh in kiew sie
schrecken auf als ihre hauptstadt von
explosionen erschüttert wird der
schwerste angriff seit langem
wir sind rausgegangen da war eine frau
im flur die einfach nur rannte sie war
an der bushaltestelle es flog direkt
über ihr sie hat es mit eigenen augen
gesehen und hatte große angst
keine toten aber ein verletzter so
vitali klitschko bürgermeister der stadt
moskau spricht wie immer von einem
erfolgreichen angriff sie hätten gezielt
waffenlieferungen aus europa zerstört
hochpräzise langstreckenraketen die von
russischen streitkräften auf die
außenbezirke von kiew abgefeuert wurden
haben t 72 panzer zerstört die von
osteuropäischen ländern geliefert wurden
wie auch andere gepanzerte fahrzeuge
weiterhin hart umkämpft der osten wie
die stadt hier wäre donetzk während
moskau fortschritte meldet gibt die
ukraine an einen gegen angriff gestartet
zu haben was der britische geheimdienst
bestätigt
tatsächlich hatten wir eine schwierige
situation die russen haben etwa 70
prozent der stadt kontrolliert aber in
den letzten zwei tagen sind sie
zurückgedrängt worden die stadt ist
jetzt in zwei hälften geteilt
in der nachbarstadt lizenz zerstörte
straßen zerstörte gebäude die russen
hätten kirchen denkmäler im land
vernichtet so der ukrainische präsident
russland zerstört absichtlich und
systematisch das kulturelle und
historische erbe der ukraine ein staat
der dies tut kann kein mitglied der
unesco sein und kann nicht bei der un
bleiben als wäre nichts passiert
bombardements auch in slogans einwohner
verlassen ihre stadt richtung west
ukraine abschied nehmen und dann weg der
krieg rückt auch hier immer näher
ja und in diesem krieg zerstören die
russischen truppen gezielt ukrainische
straßenbrücken eisenbahnschienen was
hano in der ukraine was hat das für
konkrete folgen
für die ukraine ist das ein absolutes
wirtschaftliches desaster muss man ganz
klar sagen wir sind hier in israel das
ist an der donau hierher führt
normalerweise eine eisenbahnlinie auf
der die ganzen weizen und roggen
transporte vorgenommen werden
sonnenblumenkerne und so weiter das
kommt direkt aus odessa und die
russische armee hat hier eine brücke
mehrfach mit cruise missile angegriffen
so dass hier nicht mehr die eisenbahn
fahren kann sondern alles muss jetzt mit
lkw transportiert werden über hunderte
kilometer und das hat dazu geführt dass
wir hier 4000 an manchen orten sogar
8000 lkw stehen haben die leute stehen
hier seit mehr als vier wochen teilweise
und können ihre getreide lieferungen
nicht entladen die häfen sind dafür
nicht ausgelegt das dauert alles viel zu
lange und viele haben gesagt sie werden
hier nie wieder herkommen das heißt das
getreide wird ja auch nicht mehr
rauskommen selbst verdienen sie nichts
mehr und alle sagen die eigentlich das
eine russland führt hier einen
vernichtungskrieg an auch einen
wirtschaftlichen vernichtungskrieg gegen
uns in der ukraine
über die wirtschaftlichen folgen des
krieges der bombardements dankeschön
johannes hano aus der ukraine
ja und wegen der kämpfe sind bisher mehr
als
760.000 ukrainische geflüchtete nach
deutschland gekommen vor allem frauen
und kinder wir wollen schauen wie die
integration läuft farben cool aber dafür
in einem ort in niedersachsen unterwegs
sprachkurs im niedersächsischen
delligsen dreimal die woche büffeln sie
gemeinsam für die ukraine ist es der
erste deutschkurs allah und ihre nichte
alexandra sind mitte märz aus der west
ukraine geflohen die sprachschule für
sie beschäftigung und chance
gleichermaßen wie versuchen so gut es
geht deutsch zu lernen denn wir leben in
einem fremden land und wir sollten die
sprache können
der kurs spenden finanziert lehrerin
susanne wedemeier ist begeistert über
die fortschritte der 16 teilnehmer am
ende dieser sechs wochen können sie zum
arzt gehen formulare ausfüllen guten und
nach dem weg fragen alles mögliche was
man so im alltag braucht 64 geflüchtete
vor allem frauen und kinder sind hier in
delligsen untergekommen an der
weiterführenden schule bekommen die
schulpflichtigen kinder einen tag in der
woche deutsch förderunterricht
mein lieblingsfach ist
den rest der woche nehmen sie am
normalen unterricht teil obwohl sie
deutsch lernen in manchen fächern haben
die ukrainischen schüler die nase vorn
sie sind auf jeden fall disziplinierter
und sie sind besser in mathe dass
sprache der schlüssel zur integration
ist zeigt marina drei monate ist sie
hier und hat in der örtlichen bäckerei
schon einen job gefunden ich habe
hier in delligsen könnten sie sogar noch
flüchtlinge aufnehmen und den menschen
zumindest auf zeit ein zuhause geben
der sozialverband vdk sieht in der neuen
energie pauschale der bundesregierung
eine ungleichbehandlung und will dagegen
klagen vdk-chefin bentele argumentiert
in der bild am sonntag alle rentnerinnen
und rentner oder menschen die kranken
oder elterngeld bekommen gingen leer aus
die 300 euro pauschale ist für einkommen
steuerpflichtige erwerbstätige bestimmt
an der unglücksstelle war garmisch
partenkirchen laufen die komplizierten
aufräumarbeiten am freitag kamen fünf
menschen ums leben als der regionalzug
entgleiste eine person schwebt in
lebensgefahr
vermisste gibt es jetzt keine mehr
teilte die polizei heute mit die trauer
ist groß nach dem unglück barbara lueg
sie trauern um die opfer und beten für
die verletzten heute morgen gottesdienst
in der pfarrkirche sankt martin in
garmisch
ich weiß gar nicht was man dazu
das ist ganz furchtbar
trost und umarmung des pfarrers heute
auch für joachim von der beek augenzeuge
des unfalls und genau das bewegt mich
heute darum wollte ich mich jetzt gerade
bei ihm bedanken weil mir dieses bild
von dem verrückten zug und wie die
menschen da liegen und wieder
zugänglichen den gleisen ist wie mir
auch dieses bild nicht aus dem kopf geht
katastrophal das ganze ausmaß der blick
aus der luft heute vormittag laut
polizei sind nun alle fünf todesopfer
identifiziert ein junger im
teenager-alter und vier frauen darunter
wohl auch zwei ukrainerinnen die vor dem
krieg hierher geflohen waren
morgen abend
partenkirchen einen ökumenischen
gottesdienst auf ukrainisch und deutsch
geben wenige kilometer weiter wusste der
schienenkran weitere schwere waggons auf
die straße damit sie dort verteilt und
abtransportiert werden können das ist
einfach schwierig da das ganze immer
noch abzurutschen droht wir haben
übergangs so weit gesichert müssen
trotzdem ist äußerst vorsichtig zu werke
gehen damit auch einfach unseren leuten
nichts passiert morgen wird die räumung
fortgesetzt und währenddessen suchen die
sonderermittler weiter nach der
unfallursache
auch in bangladesch ist es zu einem
schweren unglück gekommen bei einem
großfeuer in einem container depot im
osten des südasiatischen landes sind
mindestens 49 menschen gestorben mehr
als 200 menschen sollen verletzt worden
sein wie es zu dem brand kommen konnte
ist noch unklar
möglicherweise lag es an chemikalien die
explodiert sind der rettungseinsatz
läuft noch enormen teil berichtet
unter kontrolle ist die lage noch immer
nicht container qualmen container
brennen in diesem trümmerfeld müssen die
einsatzkräfte extrem vorsichtig sein
keiner kann weitere explosionen
ausschließen zur stunde überall nur
fragezeichen
die ursache für dieses unglück kann erst
nach umfassenden untersuchungen geklärt
werden wir können hier nicht spekulieren
die ermittlungen wurden aufgenommen
in der nacht bricht das feuer im
container depot aus und greift schnell
um sich die feuerwehr nimmt den kampf
gegen die flammen auf in den meisten
containern textilwaren die in alle welt
verschifft werden sollen aber in einigen
auch chemikalien
hochexplosiv
das wird den rettern zum verhängnis
dutzende tote wurden heute nun schon
geborgen aber es gibt auch noch viele
vermisste
zehn minuten vor dem unglück habe ich
noch mit ihm telefoniert seitdem habe
ich nichts mehr gehört ich weiß nicht
was mit meinem bruder ist so viele
verletzte mit schwersten verbrennungen
am ganzen körper in den krankenhäusern
chittagong kämpfen sie ums überleben das
ist das wichtigste danach aber wird die
quälende frage kommen die das
billiglohnland bangladesch schon oft
gehört hat wird genug getan für die
sicherheit am arbeitsplatz oder ist
dieses feuer eine weitere katastrophe
die hätte verhindert werden können
über frankreich ziehen derzeit besonders
heftige stürme hinweg von mindestens
einem todesopfer und 15 verletzten ist
die rede auch über süddeutschland und
luden sich am nachmittag schon mehrere
schwere gewitter im allgäu fiel dabei in
kurzer zeit besonders fiel hagel die
feuerwehr musste mit radladern anrücken
um die blockierten straßen zu holen
in london wird weiter kräftig gefeiert
70 jahre auf dem thron das rechnen viele
menschen in großbritannien ihrer queen
hoch an gestern gab es ein großes
konzert am buckingham palast heute im
ganzen land picknicks in gärten und
parks wurde gemeinsam gestemmt am
nachmittag dann ein weiterer höhepunkt
in london der große festzug diana
zimmermann hat alles für uns verfolgt
zum krönenden abschluss zeigte sich die
jubilarin dann doch noch einmal kurz auf
ihren balkon und hörte gerührt wie die
menge er aus voller brust ein gott
schütze die queen st
[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele tausende hatten am vierten und
letzten tag des thronjubiläums die
sieben jahrzehnte der regentschaft von
elizabeth zweiter an sich vorüber ziehen
lassen ein festumzug der die monarchien
mit liedern tänzen und vielen puppen
ehrte er
und so gibt uns die gelegenheit alte
erinnerungen noch mal aufleben zu lassen
und neue zu schaffen
normalerweise würden wir ein bisschen
komisch angeschaut aber heute passen wir
hier gut rein
gestern abend biete künftige könig eine
ansprache
und bedankte sich bei seiner mutter für
ihren lebenslangen einsatz
du machst und weist mit uns und am
wichtigsten fast 70 jahre lang für uns
dar
bei dem gigantischen konzert vor dem
palast traten neben vielen anderen green
rod stewart und diana ross auf während
die königlichen nachfahren brav und wie
alle anderen den junioren jack
schwenkten
höhepunkt der ton und lichtshow aber war
ein kleiner film in dem die jubilarin
die hauptrolle spielt mit königlicher
selbstironie sie im buckingham palace
und trinkt tee mit einer weiteren
britischen ikone paddington bär wünsch
dir ein glückliches jubiläum und bedankt
sich für alles
das werde kein
jubelstimmung in party laune gab es bei
der deutschen fußball nationalmannschaft
dagegen ja nicht gerade jetzt da kann
man ja kann man nicht sagen dafür war
dass nations league spiel in bologna
gegen italien mit dem 1 1 am ende zu
fehlerbehaftet die offensive zu harmlos
es gibt also viel zu tun für
bundestrainer hansi flick der aber
immerhin auch im zehnten spiel
ungeschlagen bleibt ein abend der
ernüchterung in bologna das fliegt ihm
wollte einen namhaften gegner schlagen
und ein intensives spiel zeigen beides
ist nicht gelungen so war es nur ein
mäßiger start in die nächstens league
ich glaube einfach dass dass wir vieles
besser machen können das war so im
groben nicht ganz unseren anspruch aber
das muss ja auch ganz klar sagen vorne
fehlte torgefahr hinten stabilität
italien die nach 70 minuten mit
pellegrini in führung das neu formierte
mancini team verlangte der deutschen
auswahl alles ab doch drei minuten nach
dem 1 0 zeigte dass frick team comeback
qualitäten die zum ausgleich führten wir
müssen sowieso erstmal auf uns gucken
gucken dass wir das besser machen gegen
die engländer und so wie wir jedes spiel
angehen wollen wir auch gegen die
engländer gehen dienstag die nächste
chance ein fußball schwergewicht zu
schlagen
das dann live im zdf
triathletin laura philipp ist wieder
europameisterin über die ironman distanz
und das in einer farbe zeit philipp
gewann in hamburg nach 3,8 kilometer
schwimmen 180 kilometer radfahren und 42
kilometer laufen in acht stunden 18
minuten und 20 sekunden
die weltweit zweitschnellste zeit einer
triathleten bei einem langdistanz
triathlon
und zum tennis er hat es mal wieder
getan rafael nadal aus spanien hat zum
14 mal die french open in paris gewonnen
dieses mal zog der norweger kasper roth
nach drei sätzen den kürzeren
noch nie zuvor wird sich ein siegerpokal
für rafael nadal so federleicht
angefühlt haben die heute nachmittag in
paris gegen einen chancenlosen gegner
den norweger caspary zelebrierte der
martina sein einzigartiges
sandplatztennis schon nach gut zwei
stunden und drei einseitigen setzen
krönte sich nadal mit seinem vierzehnten
erfolg bei den french open endgültig zum
könig von paris
ich weiß nicht was in zukunft passieren
wird aber ich werde alles daransetzen
weiterzumachen
beeindruckend und bewundernswert auch
mit 36 jahren hat rafael nadal immer
noch neue sportliche ziele
es wurde gemunkelt ob er aufhört aber er
macht weiter so gut spielt will ja danke
katja wir haben ja schon erste bilder
der unwetter in deutschland gezeigt und
es bleibt unruhig der deutsche
wetterdienst warnt aktuell vor schweren
gewitter mit sturm und hagel im südosten
von bayern morgen dann gibt es eine
mischung aus sonne wolken und einzelnen
schauern im nordwesten und am alpenrand
vereinzelt auch gewitter die höchstwerte
liegen zwischen 18 und 27 grad
christian sievers begrüßte hier zum
heute journal um 21.45 sagt es morgen
und wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
abend
[Musik]